All right! Hello and welcome
everyone. This is ActInf BookStream
number 2.0. We are going to be
discussing the textbook "Active
Inference, the Free Energy Principle in
Mind, Brain and Behavior, 2022.
Textbook by Thomas Parr, Giovanni
Pazulo, and Karl Friston. In
this Livestream with Ali and I, we're
going to be giving some overviews and
some kind of points that you'll want to
have in mind, little bit of background
and context. Specifically on chapters
one, two, three and six,
we're going to do more live streams in
the future that will cover the other
chapters. There's ten chapters overall,
and the goal of this live stream is to
use the live stream format to produce
materials that we can then clip out so
that the textbook groups, which we have
multiple ongoing cohorts at the
institute so that those textbook groups
can be really engaging and discussion
oriented. Because after several cohorts
of going through this, ali and I and
others have started to kind of hone our
understanding of the textbook. And so we
are starting to feel ready to put down
some background and context zero videos.
And then ideally, people who are
participating in the textbook group
cohorts will be able to view and think
about those videos leading up to a
discussion so that when we do have the
discussions in the textbook group, that
those can be maximally interactive and
engaging. So before we jump into chapter
one, Ali, do you want to just add
anything about the textbook or anything
else? Hello. I'm ali. I'm very happy
and excited to be here to discuss the
book that we've fallen in love for the
last year. And despite the fact that
we've been studying and discussing this
book for more than a year, there's still
a lot to learn and unpack. So yeah,
great. All right, so then
we will begin in just a few seconds the
chapter one and overview.
All right, this section is going to be
the chapter one and overview of the
active inference textbook. So shown here
are the table of contents. There are ten
chapters and three appendices in this
book, and they're separated into part
one with chapters one through five.
Andy Clark, two, chapters six through
ten. Ollie, do you want to give any
overview thoughts on the organization or
structure of the book?
Okay.
Can you hear me now? Sorry. Yes. Okay,
so part one is basically more line
in terms of the theoretical construction
of the active inference, and it provides
some conceptual and theoretical tools
to be utilized in the second part,
because for the second part,
we mostly deal with the practical side
of active inference, how to actually
implement active inference to model some
of the systems of interest. So that's
basically the main justification behind
dividing up these chapters into two.
Great. All right, we're going to pass
over the short preface written by Karl
Friston, but it's worth a read. It's
only several pages long, so let's go to
chapter one overview. So do you have any
opening thoughts on chapter one or where
does one even begin with such a book?
Sure, yeah. For chapter one,
I think probably the most
central theme of chapter one is about
the two different approaches to active
inference, namely the high road and the
low road. And I think it provides
a really nice perspective to view kind
of the whole picture and how the
different components of active inference
fit together. But also
I highly recommend chapter 13 from
this book, andy Clark and andy
Clark and his critics, written by
chapter 13, I think is entitled beyond
the Desert Landscape, written by Karl
Friston in which he provides more
elaborate and a bit philosophical
reasoning behind what exactly are
low road and high road and what are the
aims of each approach and the
distinction between those two? So for
chapter one we begin obviously with an
introductory paragraph which sets the
stage for all
the components that would be discussed
in this chapter. But a very important
section I believe is section two here
which is how do living organisms persist
and act adaptively? Which is basically
the main question active inference is
trying to address. So if
we want to describe
active inference minimalistically
with only one sentence or two,
probably we can say something to the
effect that it's a theory that address
this very question here. So I
why they've opened up this chapter with
important question and then section
three, which is again a continuation
of section one but a bit more
specifically about active inference and
how active inference is addressing
the question provided in the section
two. So basically again,
ActInf inference is a modeling framework
for modeling the behaviors from first
principles and what is
meant by first principles will be
elaborated upon in the following
chapters, following sections and also
obviously in the following chapters.
But very briefly, it's a kind of
modeling framework that tries to somehow
use variational principles
such as free free energy principle,
construct modeling and mathematical
tools that would enable us to describe
dynamical systems of living
and even nonliving agents in terms of
those variational principles and how
those agents or those systems are
coupled with their environment.
So that's basically the
unificatory principle that is
at the heart of this active inference
approach because yes, exactly here
it's a kind of description of this
action perception loop that is at the
heart of active inference or FEP
framework. And then
we go to chapter sorry,
section 1.4 which is
again a description of the structure
of the book and why those two parts are
divided as such. So as I
said earlier, first part is more
concerned with the theoretical
underpinnings of active inference and
the second part is more about the
practical side of it as we see in these
subsection headings here.
And then a very important diagram
which will provide very helpful as we
whole book is provided in Figure
1.2 which kind of ties
all the different strands of various
related theories such as predictive
coding, predictive processing, Bayesian
brain hypothesis and so on into a
kind of unified and integrated framework
by using those two trajectories of
constructing active inference, namely
the high road and the low road. So it
literally here is represented as the
high road and the low road in this
diagram. So,
very briefly, high road is
a kind of top down approach to active
inference. It begins with the question
how things should act if they exist,
if they persist through time. Sorry. In
other words, it kind of sets
the stage for developing the concept of
markup blankets. And then obviously
by setting that also
surprise minimization,
it attempts to elaborate that road
by adding other aspects of modeling
other aspects of theory such as
predictive processing, self evidencing,
autopoiesis and so on and then reach an
integrated version of active inference
which is basically an integration
between perception and action. So I
believe the main thing that sets active
inference apart from all the other
related theories such as predictive
processing and predictive coding is the
very deep integration of action and
perception. So action is not just some
afterthought or some additional
component that needs to be accounted
for. It is deeply woven into the
fabric of the theory. So, as we'll
see especially in chapters two and
three, even the mathematical formalism
for perception and action are
interestingly similar to each other and
even symmetric. And it shows that
perception and ActInf are actually not
separate and distinct, totally distinct
entities and concepts. And active
inference definitely provides a
very promising framework to integrate
them into a holistic framework.
And another approach to construct
that same theory is to begin with
the probabilistic description of
Bayes theorem and try
to build up the formalism of active
inference using theorem
and Bayesian statistical inference.
So again, we here see some
very apparently
different and distinct strands such as
predictive coding, Bayesian brain
hypothesis and so on. But as we see,
all of those different strands can be
united and tied together within this
low road approach to ActInf inference.
I'll just give one short thought.
Yeah, just one short thought. Thank you
Ollie, for these great summaries. The
low road and the high road are going to
be explored in a lot more detail in the
coming chapters two and three. We can
think of the high road as being a why
because it describes how persistent or
remeasurable systems exist. Now, they
might be using base theorem or they
might be using any other kind of
mechanism internally. But the high road
is describing the why of existence from
the low road. The bottom up approach is
kind of like a how you could use base
theorem to describe persistent
autopoietic entities, or you could use
base theorem for other purposes too. So
where these two roads intersect is
active inference, and we have a lot more
discussion coming and of course unpacked
in the textbook groups about how these
really map on to bottom up and top down
causation and the plurality of whys that
we approach in different settings. Good
to continue?
Yes, sure. Some of the
coming sections of this chapter,
continuing from page eight, are going to
describe what are happening in the next
chapters. So chapter two is going to set
out the low road perspective. Chapter
three is going to describe the high
road. Chapter four we will unpack
active inference more formally. That's
one of the math heavy chapters. Chapter
five will move from formal treatments to
biological implications of active
inference with a special focus on
mammalian neurophysiology.
Chapter five sets out the process theory
associated with active inference and
gives a lot of hands on and empirical
examples. And that's a lot of the first
part of the book. They're then going to
summarize some of the key points and
distillations from that theory heavy
first section. One of them is that, as
Ali mentioned, perception and action are
complementary processes and ways that
fulfill the same imperative free energy
minimization. We sometimes summarize
that by saying that in the pursuit of
the minimization of free energy, agents
can either change their mind or change
the world. Change your mind is
associated with perception and learning
and those are distinguished later and
changing the world is associated with
action. There's some discussion about
action selection and optimal policy
selection and all cognitive operations
in active inference are conceptualized
as inference over generative models. So
the true kernel, the cognitive kernel of
active inference is going to be the
generative model. Want to pick up from
here or give any thoughts on generative
models and then carry on? Thanks Ollie.
Just one point is there is a
common misconception about generative
models, which is that generative models
only refers to the inner states of the
system and also its markup blanket. But
actually generative model kind of
encompass all the states of interest of
the situation we're trying to model. So
it also encodes the probabilistic
information about the external states as
well. So generative model can be thought
of as kind of the
whole state of the system and by system
here I dean the coupled
dynamics between the internal and
external states. So that might
be helpful to keep in mind.
Great. One other distinction that comes
up and is used a lot nowadays, although
it's not always used in prior
literature, is the distinction between
the generative model and the generative
process. We're going to come back to it,
but usually the generative model is
being used to describe our statistical
model of the agent of interest. And the
generative process is the process that
generates observations that are then
passed to the generative model as
observations. However, because
generative models can be generative
processes for each other, these two are
not necessarily distinct in principle.
So in different simulations and in
different specific cases, generative
models can also be generative processes
for each other. That leads us towards
talking about ecosystems of shared
intelligence and interactions amongst
generative models. But when we're
talking about generative model, it's
like the organism or the system of
interest that we're focused on.
There are some more themes that arise
from the first half of the book. Now
we're on page eleven action is
quintessentially, goal directed and
purpose of we talk a lot about how
preference plays a role in shaping
action prediction in active inference.
And the goal directed nature of active
inference will be unpacked. In chapters
two and three, they discuss how various
constructs of active inference have
plausible biological analogues in the
brain. Once one has defined a specific
generative model for a problem at hand,
one can move from active inference as a
normative theory to active inference as
a process theory which makes specific
empirical predictions. And there's many,
many interesting philosophy of science
type discussions that we have about
explain predict, design control. And
then we get to section 1.4.2,
giving overview on part two, active
inference in practice. So I'll just
continue on. Chapter six is going to
introduce a recipe for building active
inference ModelStream. So this is where
the step by step comes into play. It's
going to give a sequence of steps and
approaches that you can take to go from
understanding the structural aspects of
a system or phenomena of interest and
build your way towards having an active
inference model that can then be
implemented in code. And we have various
examples and we're there in the textbook
group to work with everyone who wants to
take this journey. But chapter six is
going to describe that process of
building the active inference generative
model. So that's a recipe chapter and
there's a lot more that goes into the
restaurant also as we kind of have fun
exploring. Chapters seven and eight are
like a pair and they describe two
different broad families of generative
models. Now these two families of
generative models, they work well, they
play well with each other, but they are
very educationally relevant to also
consider separately. Chapter seven is
going to focus on the discrete time
generative model and chapter eight is
going to focus on the continuous time
generative models. And again, these
discrete and continuous time models can
be nested and interoperable. However,
they do describe some very important
different situations. And so chapter
seven and eight have a lot of technical
information on the discrete and
continuous time formulations of active
inference and also about how they
integrate together. Chapter nine is
illustrations of how active inference
models can be used to analyze data from
behavioral experiments. And so this kind
of goes beyond chapter six's recipe and
it talks about some of the process of
making a behavioral experiment and then
using the outcomes of that behavioral
experiment, the data from that
experiment and using that to
parameterize and do statistics with the
active inference generative model, and
chapter ten brings it all together.
Chapter ten is a lot like chapter one,
and we've even joked of reading the book
backwards. That's how great chapter ten
is. So for those who are reading chapter
one, consider reading chapter ten next
and then picking back up with chapter
two because chapter ten is going to give
some judgments and also sketch some
exciting future directions for where
active inference is in relationship to
other fields and where it's going. I
also second that. Yeah,
the second part of the book illustrates
a broad variety of models of biological
and cognitive phenomena. So it's an
application oriented second half of the
book, and we have a lot of accessory
code and approaches and notebooks, so 1
may not find that this is the one stop
shop that they were looking for.
However, for those who dive in, there's
absolutely more than enough to scaffold
their learning journey.
And then section 1.5 is the summary.
The chapter introduces the active
inference approach to explain biological
problems from a normative perspective
and previews some implications of this
perspective that will be unpacked in
later chapters. It describes the
structural outline of the book,
chapters one through five being theory,
chapters six through ten being practice.
And then it signals that the next two
chapters are going to develop the low
and the high road perspectives. And
altogether, that is chapter one. Any
other thoughts on chapter one?
Not as specifically, but I think it
provides a really good context to the
rest of the book in terms of how all
the different elements of active
inference comes into play in addressing
different problems. Different problems.
Awesome.
On to chapter two, the low road to
active inference. So all chapters begin
with a short quotation, and the
quotation here reads, my thinking is
first and last and always for the sake
of my doing. William James so even
before reading the chapter, these
quotations are often great places to
jump off and have a discussion. So
Ollie, please begin and go as long as
you want on the low road to active
inference. Okay,
I guess chapter two,
as the title suggests, it's the
construction of active inference theory
from the viewpoint of the low road
active inference. So it begins by
providing this notion of perception as
inference, because more often than not,
we usually think of perception as
something just in a computational
sense of sense is processing
of the inputs, or rather it's a raw
processing of the inputs. But here it
shows that it can also be described as,
or even more accurately described as a
kind of inference. So it's not just a
simple and raw processing of the inputs,
as my computational model or
a computer analogy might suggest. It's
more like something that
we predict and then we
compare our inputs or the inputs we
get from the stimuli with our
prediction and then try to somehow
minimize that prediction error.
So I believe that this notion
of perception as inference is the
most central notion of all
the related theories of predictive
coding, predictive processing, Bayesian
brain hypothesis. So up to now,
active inference is not very different
from all the other theories.
It's basically a subset or a variant
of those theories, but then it
progresses into distinguishing
the active inference from all the other
theories and how it stands apart from
the other ones. So in
section 2.1, we began
with some of the basics of probability
theory, namely the base theorem in box
2.1 and some simple examples
about how base theorem can be applied.
And again, a very important
page or important part of this section
will be page 20, which describes
the concept of surprisal and
specifically the statistical surprisal
and how it differs from the
phenomenological surprise or
psychological surprise.
How we can formulate the statistical
surprise. Yes, just to catch up here
this example that's going to come back
again and again is a person who's
guessing the object that's in their hand
and it could be a frog or an apple and
the object is going to jump or not. And
so that's used as a way to talk about
the Bayesian updating that forms the
kernel of a variety of Bayesian brain
like models, including ActInf inference.
And then there are the presentation of
the exact Bayes. So in simple cases,
you can compute exactly what you want.
With Bayes theorem, however, it's a lot
more effective on large data sets to use
certain approximations and heuristics
that we're going to be discussing. And
then Ali has highlighted that
there are two concepts that are very
closely related to each other regarding
surprise. There's surprise by itself and
then there's Bayesian surprise. So
please pick up there. What are surprise
and Bayesian surprise and why do they
matter here?
Yes, well, surprise,
I mean the regular surprise as we're all
familiar with is something more
related to our sense of surprise or
psychological sense of surprise of
observing some unexpected phenomena or
unexpected behavior. But Bayesian
surprise or statistical surprise is
of course closely related with the
psychological sense of surprise, but a
bit more rigorous in which it's a way to
compare two probabilistic information
using callback libel or divergence and
somehow getting the I
mean how unexpected that information
emerging from callback divergence and
they call it the surprisal. So surprisal
in other words, is a way to formulating
those unexpected probabilistic
information and it doesn't necessarily
align war maps unto perfectly
our psychological sense of surprisal.
But as I said, it's closely related with
that. Yes, by surprise,
please.
No, you take it, Allie. I know, I was
just going to say that. I was just going
to say that by surprise, almost in the
rest all the other sections and chapters
of the book, we basically mean this
Bayesian surprise sense of the world.
And in order to distinguish that with
the regular sense of surprise,
sometimes in the literature surprisal is
used to refer to Bayesian Surprise.
Yes. So they're both measured in
information theoretic units. This is all
happening in information geometric
spaces. The first concepts of surprise
is applied to a given single
observations. How surprising is that one
observation? And so in that sense it's a
lot like the Z score of a data point
coming in with respect to a statistical
distribution. So it's like you have a
height distribution in a classroom and
you measure one person and then you can
say what is the Z score of that
measurement? Was it right at the center
of the distribution with a z score of
zero or were they two standard
deviations higher with a zscore of two?
So it's kind of like that. And that's
why there's a discussion of probability
distributions and their support, which
is the x values for which they're
defined. And surprise function with the
fancy I. And that's going to be a
function that helps you compute how
surprising each observation is given a
parameterization of that distribution.
Whereas this Bayesian Surprise is more
related to learning. It has to do with
how much updating happens between the
prior and the posterior and that's
before and after the observation. So one
could imagine a surprising observation
surprise concept, one that either does
or doesn't update the prior into a very
different posterior. So as Ollie
mentioned, they are not exactly the
same, but it's going to be important to
understand how they're different. And
that's worked out again in the case of
the apple jumping box 2.2
continues with a discussion of
expectations. Now, expectation in
everyday parlance might be specifically
referring to something in the future
like I expect it to rain tomorrow. And
in statistics, when we talk about the
expectation, we're talking about the
weighted average or the center of
gravity of a distribution. And that can
be in both a discrete distribution, at
which point you have a weighted sum, or
a continuous distribution, in which case
it's an integral. So you can have an
expectation for the humidity tomorrow.
And so that might refer to the center of
gravity at a t equals plus one.
But just taken alone,
expectation means center of gravity of a
statistical distribution, not
anticipation. Section 2.3
is going to describe how some of this,
how this low road that we're on is going
to connect to biological inference.
There's more discussion of the
generative model and the generative
process and a little bit of a hint that
the generative model captures aspects of
the generative process, which is where
we see a lot of the classical cybernetic
theorems and concepts like Requisite
diversity, good regulator theorem and so
on. However, the generative model does
not have to be exactly isomorphic with
the generative process. For example,
the generative process, the temperature
in the room might be a continuous
variable, but then the generative model
might be discrete only, modeling integer
based temperatures or might be
categorical like too hot, just right,
and too cold. So there's a lot of
articulations that can be done because
of how flexible and interoperable
generative models are with each other.
Figure two is going to expand
upon that chapter one representation of
the cybernetic action perception loop.
And we're going to see this more in
terms of a generative model and
generative process articulation. And
there are incoming speaking from the
perspective of the generative model,
the agent. There are incoming and
outgoing dependencies in this graph.
And this is a little bit like a schema,
more so than a formal graph, but also it
is like a Bayesian graph where nodes are
variables and edges are causal
relationships. And so we have the
internal states of the model, the
external states of the generative
process, and then the blanket states
that make internal and external states
conditionally independent. And again,
speaking from the perspective of the
agent, although there is a symmetry, we
can talk about the incoming sensory
signals happening from the observations
handed from the process passed on to the
internal states of the generative model
and then the outgoing actions that are
selected that then can influence the
hidden state of the world. For example,
going and turning on the heater to
increase the temperature in the room.
And so this action perception loop or
particular partition is going to get
explored in a lot more detail in the
coming sections. Previous section
2.3 was on perception as inference and
now action as inference is going to be
discussed. And that is where they say
the discussion to this point is common
to all Bayesian brain theories. We now
introduce the simple but fundamental
advance offered by active inference,
which is the extension of this
inferential perspective to consideration
of action as inference.
Perception and action cooperate to
realize a single objective.
Section two five is about minimizing the
discrepancy between the model and the
world. We already described that there's
two ways for this to happen change your
mind and change the world. That's how
the discrepancy can be reduced or
managed.
We see a variant of the action
perception loop where the agent is
making action prediction models
of the world that through perception are
being juxtaposed with observations
handed from the generative process the
world and a discrepancy is realized,
some nonzero discrepancy. And then
here are those two paths to minimize
free energy, change beliefs by
perception and learning, or change the
world through action prediction
two six is going to discuss how the
exact Bayesian approach described
earlier is absolutely spot on if you
have infinite computing resources.
However, we're often interested in rapid
or large data sets where we want
to be able to get approximate Bayesian
computation or probably approximately
correct computation in a vastly
accelerated fashion. And so that is
going to be approached using what's
called variational Bayesian inference.
That's unpacked in chapter four. But it
suffices to say that variational
Bayesian inference implies substituting
two intractable quantities the posterior
probability and log model evidence with
two quantities that approximate them but
can be computed efficiently the
approximate posterior Q and A
variational free energy. So it
transforms an intractable estimation
problem into a highly tractable
optimization problem. Pick up from
there. Ali.
Yes, but sorry. I just wanted to
point out a couple of things,
especially about section 2.3, because I
believe it. It is one of the crucial
sections of this chapter and in fact,
the whole book, because it provides some
of the justifications of using Bayesian
inference as opposed to some other
mathematical techniques such as maximum
likelihood estimation. But more
important than that, I think it's this
concept of optimality which comes into
play in almost everywhere in
the literature and of course, in this
book. So there are actually two notions
of optimality which is not discussed in
detail here, namely Bayesian optimality
and Jane's optimality. But in some of
the recent papers on Bayesian mechanics,
dalton, Sactavato, Maxwell, Ramstead and
others have shown that those two
concepts of optimality are actually
congruent with each other. So that's one
of the reasons that the
duality between FEP free energy
principle and constrained maximum
entropy principle can
be I mean, it's one of the
justifications for providing
that dual formalism between those two.
But another point I wanted to mention
here is because I've seen that using the
word hidden state can be
a bit confusing for some people because
when we observe something
as an observation, obviously it is not,
quote unquote, hidden, right? So what a
hidden state here refers to is actually
the hidden cause of that observation.
So it's not that the observation itself
is hidden from the observation or it's
unobserved. So that might be a bit
confusing if we don't take into
consideration the exact meaning of the
hidden state or latent state here and in
the rest of the literature. So
continuing from Section 2.6 here
we see one of the two central equations
of active inference, which is equation
2.5 for variational
free energy. So it's,
as I said, understanding this equation
and how each line of its formulation
represents in terms of the trade
off between energy, entropy or
complexity and accuracy or divergence.
And evidence is key to understanding
almost everything in the rest of the
book and in many other literature on
active inference. So this is
the perceptual part of active inference.
So variation free energy is a
parameter, that is
a notion that parameterizes the
surprisal of our perceptual information
we have about the external states. And
then we'll see in the next section
the related and almost symmetrical
formulation to variation of free energy,
namely expected free energy, which is
basically the action part of the active
inference. So we can see how those two
can somehow be seen
as a kind of unified formalism but
described in alternate expressions.
But another thing about equation 2.5 is
it may be a bit, I don't know,
daunting to see all. The relations
between those three lines of equation
and how we can get from one to the
other. So there are some
supplementary materials that we have
developed in the past weeks which
I think can help in clarifying
how the derivations of these three lines
of equation be done. So I hope
they would be clarifying and
help to understand how those three lines
relate to each other.
But the key point here is to
understand that variation of free energy
is not something absolute,
but it's just an upper bound for the
minimization. So as Daniel just
mentioned, it's untractable
to have an absolute amount for
the surprisal to be minimized. So we
need to have an upper bound in order
to make that more tractable because by
Jane's inequality, as we'll saw in
chapter four, I think we
can see that how the upper bound
of a surprisal necessarily
provides a condition for minimizing the
precise or the
exact free energy. And that's the
key insight of equation 2.5 or
the notion of variation of free energy
which is to provide this upper bound
instead of the exact amount of surprisal
to be minimized. Yeah, what I'll add
there is if you knew exactly how well
you should be surprised by a given data
point Y, then you would have had the
optimal model. However, that is not
tractable. And so by making a quantity
that's always higher or an upper bound,
the variational free energy F, which is
a function of broadly Q, our beliefs or
variational beliefs which are built in a
way that makes them very compositional,
very optimizable, very interpretable and
data. And we can reduce the divergence
here, the KL divergence with a double
line between Q, our beliefs and P,
the kind of actuality of it. And if we
can reduce this divergence, in other
words, minimize the free energy, then we
will come closer and closer to the true
surprise function and do that in an
attractable, incrementally, optimizable
way. So equation 2.5 is going
to be the variational free energy,
different ways that it can be
represented as it takes in data and
beliefs about the world Q. And then
this is going to be expanded into the
future to include action with G,
the expected free energy. Now, there's a
lot more that we can say about this.
There's a lot of technicalities to go
into. But broadly, notice that g the
expected free energy is a functional of
policy pi because it's only being
evaluated to select amongst different
action outcomes. Pi and another
important difference is that it's going
to be describing sensory outcomes that
haven't yet happened. A sort of what
would I perceive if I did A or what
if I did B? And it's that kind of
comparison that allows the expected free
energy functional here to be used in
action selection or policy selection as
inference, planning as inference.
That section is expanded upon.
And in figure two six, we see a very
nice representation of the expected free
energy equation. And then how, when
certain aspects of this equation or
situation are zeroed out, we get certain
other familiar cases. For example,
where there is no epistemic value,
there's no information to learn. Then
you get ruthless expected utility
theory. And conversely, where there is
no pragmatic value to extract.
So all outcomes are equally valid or
preferable. Then you get things like
Infomax principle and optimal Bayesian
design and then everything in between is
the space that we're interested in. And
so this figure 2.6 shows that
the expected free energy functional can
be seen as like a generalization of a
lot of other settings related to
perception and action and planning
amidst uncertainty. And section 2.9
closes the low road. They took us all
the way to active inference, from Bayes
theorem through the generative model
onto active inference and clarifies
these two notions of variational free
energy that's the real time perceptual
unfolding evidence, lower bound,
unsurprisal tractable optimizable, and
so on and f and g, the expected
free energy which is able to do planning
as inference or policy selection as
inference. Expected free energy is
fundamentally prospective and that
enables counterfactual cognition.
Section 210 summarizes active inference
is the theory of how living artifacts
underwrite their existence by minimizing
surprise or attractable proxy to
surprise variational free energy via
perception and action. And they motivate
that from a first principles base
theorem starting place. Any closing
thoughts on chapter two, Ali?
I would just humbly suggest for the
people who want to go through this
chapter to try their
best to really understand specifically
what equation 2.5 and 2.6 represents
and how I mean, how to
use those equations to describe
different situations with some
missing elements as well.
Because I believe those sections, and
particularly those equations are
absolutely essential for understanding
everything active inference related both
in the rest of this book and in
almost all. Thanks. And just the last
thought I'll give on chapter two is this
is exactly the work that we do in the
active inference textbook group. We
really welcome all backgrounds, every
single question and uncertainty you have
is beautiful. We have a lot of resources
that Ali and others make to make the
math approachable and rigorous and
natural language descriptions of the
equations and so on. So yes, it's really
important to understand the equations
because after all, that's like the
skeleton that gives meaning to our usage
and fluency of the active inference
ontology which Ali and I are speaking
right now. We're not just saying
surprise is related to this because we
felt it that way. There is an
underpinning and it is a really
interesting life's work to explore it,
but we're finding ways to communicate it
and learn and teach it better and better
every time. So that's chapter two,
that's the low road moving
on to chapter three, the high road to
active inference. And so recall that the
high road is like the why. So,
Ali, please begin, just go as long as
you want on through the high road to
active inference.
Okay, so the high road to active
inference begin with the
question about
the conditions for the persistence
of things. I mean,
what would we expect for a thing to
behave if it persists through time? And
that's why sometimes FEP is referred to
as the theory of every space thing.
And it's not absolutely everything, but
just in this sense of I mean,
persisting through time. And the notion
that allows for this thing
to act as
it persists through time is markup
blanket. So Markov blanket is one of the
most essential ingredients of the
high road approach to active inference.
And that's why this section opens up
with describing how
markup blanket allows to describe
the situation of interest through this
conceptual and mathematical tool. But
one thing that I always point out in
almost all our textbook cohorts is
in this section. It doesn't exactly
describe markup blankets rigorously
enough in terms of it's carving up the
state space and so on. So one thing
I think can be clarifying
in following all the discussions around
markup blanket is to keep in mind that
it's just a boundary in the state space.
So it's not necessarily spatial temporal
boundary, although in
many cases it manifests itself as
spatial temporal boundaries, such as
the, I don't know, cell membranes or
organelle membranes and so on. But it's
not necessarily the case. So I think it
can be helpful to keep that in mind when
we every everywhere we see markup
blanket. But in
a very simply, markup blanket is
what allows for the agent or the system
to be statistically separated from its
environment, as is shown here in Figure
3.1. So basically,
markup blanket mathematically is just
the sensory and active states together.
It consists of both of those states and
it statistically separates what happened
externally or internally from each
other. So in other words, internal
states cannot observe or infer anything
about the external states directly, but
only through the Markov blanket.
And that's why it's essential to
describe the systems in this way,
because obviously, in any sparse coupled
systems, there isn't the
possibility to observe the external
states directly, but only through
those sensory and active states. And one
other thing that I also believe can be
a bit confusing in this picture is that,
yes, typo in the ActInf estates
and sensory states because it's
important to observe that active estate
only or the flow in the active states
more precisely, only depends on
internal and markup states or blanket
states. And on the other hand, in
sensory states only depend on the
external and blanket states. So Mu and
X in those two equations should be
exchanged. Yes.
Let me just unpack before we continue.
To add before we continue. Yes. So this
is what's known as the particular
partition. And that terminology was
brought to the fore by Carl Friston's
famous monograph in 2019.
And it's a little bit of a pun. It's a
particular partition because this is
just one way to partition agent from
environment, figure from ground.
And we call what it partitions out
the blankets and internal states as the
particle. So we can think about the most
inert least cognitive particle is like a
speck of dust doing brownie and
diffusion. But also there are more
sophisticated kinds of cognitive
particles that can include world models,
counterfactuals what would happen if I
did this, all of those kinds of
sophisticated cognitive operations that
we can explore in active inference. So
note the small typo that Ali mentioned,
internal states. And also these edges
reflect causal possibilities amongst
internal, external and blanket states.
Blanket constituting the active U and
sensory y states. So these are
map, not territory. This is not a
spatiotemporal articulation. These are
like causal maps of the world that
may have to do with spatial temporal
boundaries but are not simply that. And
sensory data or sensory states flow onto
internal states. Internal states are
involved in action selection resulting
in active states which have some causal
consequence in the world, the generative
process, the external states which
results in different sensory states
coming in again. And so the Markov
blanket is what makes the internal and
the external states conditionally
independent. And that can be thought of
as just a no telekinesis, no telepathy
clause. The only way that information
comes across internal and external
states which are symmetrical with each
other is through the boundary or the
Holographic screen or the Markov
blanket.
You can continue on ali.
Okay, so the next section is
about surprise, minimization and self
evidencing. So again, this term self
evidencing is a common term in active
inference literature first proposed by
Jacob Howie. So basically it
refers to how a system or agent or
in other words a particular state can
gather the evidence for its self
persistence or self existence through
time. In other words,
by inferring the state of the
environment and comparing that
inference with its internal states or in
other words, with its generative model.
It's basically a way, I mean an
interpretation of that
kind of inference is on the one hand,
there is this dynamical interaction
between the internal and external state.
But we can somehow interpret that
physical dynamics as engaging in
the active inference or as model for
the persistence of the agent through
time. So that's basically what refers to
as self evidencing. And then
we go through the subsection 3.3.1,
which sets the stage for the recent
formulation of active inference
mechanics, which is to somehow
to interpret the ActInf surprise
minimization as minimizing
the action through the Hamiltonian
principle of least action, which is a
variational principle. And by
variational principle, what is meant
here is just a computational or
mathematical tool that allows for
the computation or specific
derivations to happen. So it's not
identical to scientific theories or
scientific, I don't know, facts or
observations. It's just a tool,
a principle mathematical tool.
So again,
one of the main misconceptions about
free free energy principle, that it is
unfalsifiable. Obviously, if we see it
in this way, it doesn't make sense to
say that a mathematical tool or
principle is unfalsifiable because it
doesn't say anything about the empirical
evidence of the phenomena we're
talking about. So that's why here it's
important to understand how the surprise
minimization can be seen as this
kind of variational principle.
And then equation
3.1 draws
the parallel between the surprisal
as defined in section in chapter two
sorry. And this chapter. So it kind of
ties up all the arguments provided in
the previous chapter with this one and
how everything comes together in a
single formulation of active inference.
But they're just the two distinct
approaches to arrive at same
destination.
And then we go also sorry,
the other important equation,
and again, another key equation here is
equation 3.2, which is kind
of sorry,
yes, equation I meant to say equation
3.2, not equation 3.1. Sorry, my bad.
So yes. The other section is
about the relations between inference,
cognition and stochastic dynamics,
as all
the previous discussions around how
the active inference can be seen as a
kind of self evidencing through the
variational principles such as
FEP comes together to reframe
the previous discussions we saw in
chapter two about perception as
inference and action as inference, and
to see the concepts of variational free
energy and expected free energy through
the lens of variational free energy.
Variational principle of least
action. So it unifies
nicely all the material from chapters
two and three into something
not necessarily distinct from each
other, but just two sides of.
Awesome. Yeah, I find Table 31 to be
very exciting. It draws together
statistical physics, Bayesian
information, information theory and
cognitive interpretations. So it's kind
of like learn one thing, learn many
things. Statistical physics has been
talking about minimization of
variational free energy for a long time,
and such methods are absolutely everyday
and professionalized. In Bayesian
statistics, active inference is using
exactly just that to describe perception
and action and so on. So that's very
exciting. Box 3.2 describes
free energy in statistical physics and
active inference. I sometimes joke that
we have a few kinds of free energy. We
have Tesla like electrical power should
be available to everybody for no cost.
We're not talking about that right now.
There's Gibbs free energy, which is the
quantity that makes chemical or
thermochemical reactions irreversible,
like the hydrolysis of ATP. And when
we're talking about variational free
energy, we're talking about an
information geometric space with similar
dynamics, similar kinetics and
thermodynamics. But rather than
describing the reaction coordinates of a
chemical reaction, we're thinking about
it in terms of Bayesian updating. And
this is all called the Bayesian
mechanics.
3.41 continues on with variational free
energy.
3.42 goes into expected
free energy. So we see this a lot f
variational, free energy, that's the
real time unfolding sensory flow and
then g expected free energy and the
policy planning as Inference section
3.5 concludes with a novel
foundation active inference to
understand behavior and cognition. And
it describes a few features of active
inference, including its distinguishing
features from a few other ways that
people have looked at behavior and
cybernetics. Section 3.6
goes into a bit more detail on models,
policies and trajectories having to do
with agency and policy selection.
3.7 reconciliation of inactive
cybernetic and predictive theories under
active inference. Again, the exact kind
of thing that there's a whole literature
on and it's always amazing to hear
everybody's perspective on in the
textbook groups. Three eight active
inference from the emergence of life to
agency and three nine summary. You want
to just give any other thoughts that you
have on chapter three.
Again, it's one of the probably most
fundamental chapters and the
topics covered in this chapter is
essential, are absolutely essential to
understand everything active inference
related. But specifically the
discussions in section 3.73.6
onward again, I believe is
really important to understand the
broader context of active inference and
how it relates to all the other
theories. But specifically, section 3.8
provides a nice view of
how we can use the
same theoretical tools to model both
nonliving dynamical systems or sparse
coupled stochastic systems and also
to the systems that
has agency or sentience. So it's a
much broader theoretical framework that
doesn't restrict itself to only
particular kinds of systems or
agents and we'll see much
more elaboration on that in the later.
Wonderful. All right, that concludes
our overview on chapter three.
Now we're going to skip to chapter six.
So again, this live stream is just
providing some materials on chapters
one, two, three and six. Eventually
we're going to get to all chapters and
version them and have as many of you as
want join into the process of
constructing these. But this is all so
that our textbook groups can be really
interactive and people can show up
having listened to these background and
context videos. All right, so now we
are in chapter six, a recipe for
designing active inference models.
Abraham Lincoln give me 6 hours to chop
down a tree and I will spend the first
four sharpening the axe. All right,
Ali, what does the quote mean? And
please lead us into this discussion.
Okay, so as the opening quotation
suggests, it's about honing
the skill set and skill set for applying
ActInf inference framework to model the
actual empirical situations that
we may use active inference for. And it
frames it as a four step recipe to
actually do this kind of model,
although it's termed as recipe. But I
believe it's more like a guideline and
it's not like, I don't know, cooking
recipe that needs to be
observed strictly.
So it's more like suggestions
or guidelines to begin
to apply active inference framework
in any kind of situation we'd like.
So section 6.2 outlines
those four steps. So the first step is
which system are we modeling in
terms of how we can define
the Markup blanket that most
effectively and efficient the problem or
question we want to explore
through that modeling through the
modeling of that situation. So first
step is about defining those boundaries
through Markov blanket. And the second
step is about what's the most
appropriate form for the generative
model because obviously we can have many
different types of generative models
depending on, again, what phenomena or
what questions we're trying to address.
The third stage is how to set up
Degenerative Model. So after settling
upon the type of Degenerative Model we
want to use, we can talk about
the details of Degenerative Model and
how it can be efficiently modeled to be
both tractable and also useful
to address the situation of interest.
And finally, how to set up the
generative process. So, as we saw in
chapter two, there's important
but slight distinction between
generative process and generative model.
So they're not always the same, but
they're closely related to each other.
Generative process, the hidden states
of the external world. And generative
model is how the agent infer about those
hidden states provided by generative
process. So,
considering that the environment
is always very complex to be
modeled precisely and exactly with
every parameter accounted for, we need
to have a restricted set of parameters
to account for in the generative
process. So that's what stage four deals
for deals about. So all of these
steps, even if not observed
or followed sequentially, are really
essential to setting up or
the initial setup of the situation
we're trying to model. And I
cannot imagine how any
scenario can progress without observing
any of these steps at least, I mean,
just by thinking about how to set up
the situation or scenario.
Awesome. And in the rest
of the chapter. Yes, just wanted to
highlight again, these steps don't have
to be followed in order. They really are
like a summary as Mark has just written
in the live chat here. It really is like
a summary of the earlier parts of the
book in terms of things that you want to
capture in your consideration. And also
it's a great way to connect a lot of the
technical ideas that are brought up
about generative model, generative
process and so on with some bigger
questions like who are we? Why are we
making this model? How is the model
going to be used? So we take that in a
lot of different ways in the textbook
groups. But which system are we
modeling? What is the most appropriate
form for the generative model? How
should we set up the generative model?
And how to set up the generative process
are all questions that must be
addressed, at least when actually coming
through with carrying out a theoretical
or empirical active inference modeling
task. And the following sections are
going to go into more detail on each of
those four questions. So Ollie, do you
want to go for this? 63 and carry on.
Okay, so section six one three is
the elaboration of the first step that
we just saw.
What systems are we modeling?
And by this question we
mean how the system carves up the state
space using the markup blanket
or more precisely, the active states and
sensory states. And I believe it
is both one
of the most fundamental and also one
of the most challenging steps to be
carried out because, well, markup
blanket is just a conceptual tool we use
to frame the natural phenomena or
any other scenario we want to model. So
that scenario or that model obviously
doesn't care about how we set up our
Markov blanket or how we knit our markup
blanket. But deciding
on a proper set of active states and
sensory states that would allow us to
address the problems we need to explore
or the questions we need to answer, is
not a trivial task. And it needs lots of
lots of consideration and even
creativity on part of the researcher or
anyone who wants to design an
active inference based model for the
problem. So that's where the
significance of doing these
kinds of modeling with the insights
and creativity of a researcher
will be obvious because it's not just
something mechanical or despite
the fact that the word recipe
can somehow make us believe that it's
just a recipe to follow. But in
actuality it's not the case at all. So
that's the
discussion of markup blanket and what
criteria we need to keep in mind to
settle upon proper
Markov blanket around our system. And
the next section, what is the most
appropriate form for the generative
model? So here again,
we can have various way
to set up our generative model in terms
of whether it's discrete or continuous
variables we want to account for about
the timescale, is it shallow or
hierarchical about
the temporal depth of the inference and
planning. So these are all problems we
need to be precise about
or questions we need to precise about
whenever we want to set up our
generative model. And then we
go to section 6.5,
how to set up the generative model. So
after precisely describing what
needs to be accounted or what parameters
and the nature of the generative model
needs to be accounted for,
then we need to
address this question of how can that
generative model be actually set up. So
setting up the variables for the
generative model will
be concerned about how those matrices as
A-B-C and D matrices can
be defined, as we saw
in chapter four. And then which parts
of the generator model are fixed and
what is learned. So again, it's really
important to know what are the dynamics
of those parameters are in terms of
the learning process and what needs
to be updated consistently or learned
as opposed to the variables that either
don't require consistent updating or
they vary quite slowly
as compared to the timescale of the
generative model. And then we
go through the process of setting
up the generative process. And as
I mentioned earlier, it is probably one
of the most complicated steps of
the recipe because of the complexity,
the enormous complexity of any real time
situation and particularly the
environment that the agent will
act and behave. But even
if there is not any strict
or, I don't know, obvious way to go
through this stage of setting up the
generative process, this section
provides some helpful criteria
or helpful points in order to help us in
that stage as well. So finally,
after going through all of these stages,
we need to somehow get I
mean, obviously we need results, and we
need to provide our results in a
we get our results from our active
inference model, and section
6.7 addresses that
very idea of how to simulate,
visualize, analyze, and fit data using
active inference. Because it's not just
enough to set up the model, we need to
get the model to work. So how can we
feed the data into the model? How can we
read the data? And finally, how can we
analyze the simulated data through the
active inference? So this
is in a way
a kind of preliminary recipe or
preliminary procedure for doing active
inference or active inference modeling,
or at least suggested way to do those
kinds of modeling. But in the subsequent
chapters, in particular chapters seven
and eight, we'll go through some helpful
cases, studies for how to actually
use these procedures to model
some real world situations.
Awesome, thanks. Well, there's a lot to
say on chapter six. One piece
that comes up a lot is what is in the
active inference kernel, the cognitive
kernel, and what are situations that we
can model with active inference.
There's a huge variety of cognitive
phenomena and statistical outcomes that
we might be interested to study like
counterfactuals and planning, like
multiscale attention covert action,
like the complex ways in which memories
might influence decision making in the
moment based upon associations made
between different sensory modalities,
every amazing real world situation you
can imagine. And it's really helpful to
think about active inference as more
like a framework of interoperable
motifs that we can compose and
indeed even be creative with rather than
giving us all the answers at the core
model. Because the kind of essential
minimal active inference model doesn't
necessarily include every single
attribute that you might be interested
in, just like any given linear
regression isn't going to include every
single feature that you're looking for.
This is happening in a different type of
modeling framework. But still, there's a
lot of customization and development
that goes into adapting or elaborating
an active inference type model for your
given system or scenario of interest.
Chapter six gives us some helpful
guidelines and things to consider,
which we've unpacked and expanded on
elsewhere. And in the textbook group,
we work together to characterize
different systems of interest, to map
different parts or different observables
from that system, using the active
inference ontology into a unified ActInf
inference type model. So chapter six
starts the second half of the book,
which is the more practice oriented part
of the book. And the rest of the part
two is going to be a lot more about the
specific kinds of generative models that
you can use discrete and continuous time
and about using them with empirical data
in chapter nine. But chapter six just
stands alone as a summary of part one of
the book in some ways, and a set of four
questions which system are we modeling?
What is the most appropriate form for
the generative model, how to set up the
generative model, and how to set up the
generative process so that we can be
active inference modelers ourselves?
All right, well, Ali, thanks so much
for all of these great conversations and
cohorts. We will be able to process this
video to clip out these first versions
of the background and context overviews,
and we'll distribute them to the cohorts
so that people can show up with their
curiosities and passions and we'll see
where that goes. Any last thoughts?
Thank you. It was a pleasure to go
through these chapters once again with
each time, obviously with a
bit more understanding than the previous
one. So I'm looking forward to the next
cohorts. Awesome. All right. Thanks,
Ollie.